[موسيقى]
ولدت لعبة الجولف عن طريق البحر ،
فقد نشأت هنا على الساحل الشرقي
لأسكتلندا على
زواحف ذات تضاريس رملية متموجة
كانت غير صالحة
للزراعة مع عدم وجود أي استخدام يُعرف باسم لينكس
لاند
خارج هذه الأراضي ، ولدت
دورات صمدت أمام الاختبار  من الوقت بدأت
[الموسيقى] في
البداية لا ، فنحن لا نتحدث عن
سانت أندروز هنا
ولكن روابط ليث هنا في إدنبرة
[موسيقى]
هذا هو المكان الذي نشأ فيه أول ذكر
لجولف الرابط
منذ عام 1453 وكان هنا في عام 1744
أن القواعد الأصلية  من لعبة الجولف
الآن ، لم يعودوا يلعبون الجولف هنا ،
ولكن بسبب ما حدث في هذا
الموقع قبل كل تلك السنوات ،
يوجد الآن وفرة من
روابط الجولف الغنية وتاريخ رياضة الجولف في هذا البلد [الموسيقي] المذهل ، حيث
يوجد أكثر من 600 ملعب غولف في
اسكتلندا
وواحد يجب عليك زيارته هو بريستويك على
الساحل الغربي ،
وهذا هو المكان
الذي أقيمت فيه أول 11 بطولة مفتوحة وما زالت
تحتفظ بالعديد من ميزاتها الأصلية
[الموسيقى]
كشعبية في  لقد نما
التخطيط الضيق للعبة السابقة وأصبح أصغر من
أن تستضيف مباراة مفتوحة آخرها
لعبت هنا في عام 1925.
[موسيقى]
منذ بريستويك استضافت ست دورات أخرى من الروابط الاسكتلندية
البطولة المفتوحة
مع سانت أندروز الذي يحمل أكبر عدد من
28.
بينما فازت في أي مكان.  في
الجزر البريطانية أمر خاص ،
هناك شيء معين في
رفع إبريق كلاريت في
جديلة جيمس اسكتلندا يتصدر القائمة التي تلتقط جميع
ألقابه الخمسة
المفتوحة هنا ، ويتبع الجديلة عن كثب من
قبل جيرسي هاري فاردين
وأمريكا توم واتسون كلاهما يفوز
بأربعة فتحات شمال  الحدود
[موسيقى]
فاز سيدي نيك فالدو بجميع ألقابه الثلاثة
في اسكتلندا ،
وكان فوزه عام 1992 في
مويرفيلد آخر مرة يرفع فيها رجل إنجليزي
الكأس